madame la ministre vous chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle les explications
de vote des groupes et le vote par
scrutin public sur le projet de loi
adopté par l'assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
pourtant on lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique et renforcement de la
résilience face à ses effets je vais
donc donner pour l'explication de vote
de 7 minutes par groupe et pour 3
minutes pour sénateur n'appartenant à
aucun groupe 3 minutes et donc donner la
parole à ronan dantec pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoires s'il
veut bien venir pour expliquer son vote
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs le
patron du programme alimentaire mondial
à cette semaine alertés sur la très
grave sécheresse qui frappe actuellement
madagascar première famine sur le
continent africain depuis longtemps sans
qu'aucune guerre ou conflit n'en soient
à l'origine cette situation n'est lié
qu'à plusieurs années de sécheresse
consécutive ce qui fait dire à la
directrice du programme alimentaire
mondial locale qu'il s'agit de la
première famille totalement liée au
réchauffement climatique
il n'ya donc et le terme est
malheureusement aujourd'hui très
galvaudé
il n'ya donc pas d'autre solution que
l'urgence de l'action et les décisions
que nous prenons aujourd'hui dont les
effets se feront pleinement sentir dans
10 ans sont donc essentiel si nous
voulons avoir une chance de stabiliser
le climat
alors nos émissions devront avoir
massivement baissé dès 2030
c'est la feuille de route que nous
fixent la communauté scientifique
l'europe est aujourd'hui le seul
continent à prendre réellement ses
responsabilités avec un objectif adopter
par le conseil européen de -55%
démission en 2030
objectif ambitieux qui nécessite un réel
effort de mutations économiques de nos
économies une transition qui doit être
notamment financé par le new green deal
cet objectif se doit donc il est adopté
au niveau européen être déclinée au
niveau des états membres c'est notre
feuille de route et le sénat l'a rappelé
en introduction avec cet amendement
commun à la plupart des groupes
politiques et je crois que cet
amendement était un moment important
pour dire notre adhésion à l'objectif de
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
le sénat a donc beaucoup travaillé et je
veux ici rendre hommage aux différents
rapporteurs qui ont tous beaucoup de
vrai plus de deux mille amendements dont
ceux du groupe écologiste qui était
adossé à notre vraie loi climat un
projet totalement quantifier qui
montrent comment la france
pourrait tenir l'objectif européen -
cinquante-cinq pour cent quarante quatre
de nos amendements ont été adoptés dont
certains réellement ambitieux et je
voulais donc remercier ici les
rapporteurs et le sénat de les avoir
voté les malgré tout il est très clair
que la loi modifié par le sénat ne
respectent toujours pas l'objectif
européen
pas plus il faut le dire que le projet
de loi initial
un rapide calcul à partir 10 des avis du
boston consulting group ou du haut
conseil pour le climat nous donne
toujours un résultat entre -30 et -35 %
en 2030
loin de l'objectif des clés en france
deux -55% c'est extrêmement
problématique
je le redis l'enjeu est bien qu à
glasgow dans la logique du mécanique de
l'école de l'accord de paris prévoient
tous les cinq ans une réévaluation des
engagements qui sont actuellement très
insuffisant donc à glasgow la communauté
mondiale et notamment les très grands
émetteurs que sont la chine et les états
unis devront prendre de nouveaux
engagements crédibilisant la trajectoire
sous les deux degrés près du 1,5 c'est
une négociation difficile je la suis
depuis 15 ans je pourrais vous en parler
longuement un rapport de force avec de
nombreuses conséquences économiques pour
chacun avec mon sont moins 55% leur à
paris en situation de force mais si
derrière l'objectif européen
il n'ya pas madame la ministre les
déclinant nationale notamment donc en
france pays garants de l'accord de paris
alors notre capacité à imposer l'effort
mondial s'effrite les négociateurs
internationaux scrutent tous y compris
les débats que nous avons aujourd'hui au
sénat et donc malheureusement notre loi
insuffisamment ambitieuse est un élément
aujourd'hui deux fragilisation de la
négociation internationale de ce fait
donc logiquement le groupe écologie ne
peut que voter contre ce texte issu de
nos travaux
car il ne répond pas à notre
responsabilité internationale en 7
minutes et ne m'en reste que trois je
n'ai pas le temps évidemment d'analysé
les avancées il y en a et les reculs il
y en a aussi
j'assisterai juste sur deux trois points
d'abord nous avons nous l'avions déjà
fait nous l'avons refait rappeler que
sans la mobilisation des collectivités
territoriales 50% des émissions liées à
la vie quotidienne
nous ne pouvons pas tenir les
engagements l'état a donné ces dernières
années des compétences collectivités à
travers notamment les pct
il n'a donné aucun financement le
milliard que nous avons votée c'est tout
simplement le financement par l'état de
la compétence que nous avons donnée aux
collectivités
j'espère que ce signal sera gardée nous
avons une stratégie assez cohérente sur
la volonté d'un transfert modal de
l'avion vers le rail par le signal prix
comme l'a signalé le rapporteur tabourot
en commission tva à 5,5 sur le
ferroviaire maintien d'une compensation
mieux préciser et maintien et c'est très
important du système de la taxe chirac
il ne doit en aucun cas l substitué par
le système d'échangé de quotas européen
ou mondial corse ya des signaux aussi
intéressant pour le développement d'une
filière photovoltaïque français je n'ai
pas le temps d'énumérer mais dans
l'autre sens
or l'autre sens art fut très clair de
limitation de la publicité à la fois sur
les gaspillage de papier ou d'énergie
mais plus largement un refus limiter les
désirs de ces produits donc que nous
savons pourtant totalement incompatible
avec nos trajectoires co2 une offensive
forte contre l'éolien terrestre humaine
offshore le rapporteur grémillet nous a
fixé en 2005 en 50 gigawatts d'offshore
avec un droit de veto des communes
riveraines sur le domaine public
maritime
c'est totalement impossible voir si le
temps le permet contradictoire ou
absurdes
le refus aussi des efforts nécessaires
dans la modification des pratiques
agricoles
c'est un classique du sénat notamment la
réduction des engrais azotés très
émetteurs de co2 madame la ministre nous
avons besoin de vous en tant de mieux
vous comprendre et à travers
le gouvernement sur la suite car cette
loi n'étant pas suffisantes par rapport
à nos propres engagements
il va falloir y revenir très vite c'est
d'abord une occasion manquée parce que
vous aviez mandaté la convention
citoyenne pour trouver des consensus et
des compromis dans la société
vous ne les avez pas respecté vous même
mais surtout maintenant que faisons nous
il est certain qu'il nous faudra y
revenir avant la programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie loi que nous
discuterons en 2023 mais d'ores et déjà
nous avons cette cmp 7 cm et madame la
ministre
et je conclurai là dessus je vous fais
une proposition très simple vous gardez
ce qu'il y avait de mieux pour le climat
à l'assemblée nationale vous gardez ce
qu'il ya de mieux au climat pour le
sénat ça fera toujours pas moi 55% mais
nous aurons progressé
merci parole et à d'autres collègues
frédéric mar chambre pour le groupe du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant il a sept
minutes de la parole
voilà monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous y
voilà
après deux semaines de débat riche et
passionné nous sommes arrivés au terme
de l'examen de ce projet de loi visant à
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
et portant résilience la résilience mes
chers collègues celui qui en parle mieux
c'est sans aucun doute boris cyrulnik
dans les travaux font autorité en la
matière le malheur n'est jamais pur pas
plus que le bonheur un mot permet de
comprendre le mystère de ce qui s'en
sont sortis la résilience qui désigne la
capacité à réussir à vivre à se
développer en dépit de l'adversité cette
adversité mes chers collègues elle est
devant nous et nous devons y faire face
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
si nous voulons être capables de réussir
de vivre et de nous développer nous ne
devons plus attendre et ne plus nous
payer de mots mais agir agir et encore
agir car alors que nous débattions sur
ce projet de loi le sixième rapport du
groupe d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat le giec a fuité
dans la presse
les experts s'y alarme des impacts
dévastateurs chorale réchauffement sur
notre planète dès les prochaines
décennies
ils rappellent l'urgence d'une action
politique ambitieuse et résolue en
faveur du climat face aux conséquences
irréversibles corps est une attitude
attentiste
le rapport apporte aussi une note
d'espoir il affirme que l'humanité peut
encore changer le cours des choses
à condition d'opérer une transformation
radicale des processus et les
comportements à tous les niveaux mais
nous savons tous les uns et les autres
et nos débats sont là pour en attester
que cette radicalité ne peut se faire
sans l'adhésion masis de nos concitoyens
au risque d'échouer lamentablement et de
nous conduire dans le mur méfions-nous
de celles et ceux qui appellent au grand
dérangement comme d'autres avant eux à
de grands bonds en avant ils mènent à
l'autoritarisme à la misère collective
dans ce cadre soyons clairs nets et
précis admettons que la france elle
prend toute sa part y compris celle de
moteurs d autres parties prenantes
depuis 2010 est notre pays mène une
action résolue concrète et ambitieuse
qui lui permet de s'affirmer comme un
leader de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique dans le monde
nous allons souvent plus loin que ce que
certains qui ont la mémoire courte
proposé d'ailleurs en 2017 et les faits
sont têtus
durant le quinquennat plusieurs mesures
significatives ont été prises 30
milliards d'euros à la transition
écologique dans le cadre de la france
l'inscription dans la loi de la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 la mise en
place d'un plan de 10 biodiversité doté
de 600 millions d'euros et portant 90
mesures parmi lesquelles figurent
l'interdiction de la plupart des
produits plastiques à usage unique
l'arrêt du projet de l'aéroport de notre
dame des landes la fermeture de
fessenheim et l'abandon du projet
montagne d'or en guyane
ce projet de loi que nous avons examinés
nous adresse je le disais le 14 juin
dernier un double défi celui de
conjuguer démocratie participative et
démocratie représentative d'une part
celui d' accélérer la transition
écologique d'autre part nous ne croyons
pas une écologie qui viendraient
simplement d'en haut c'est ce qui a
inspiré la création de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat et traduit
l'essentiel de ses engagements dans
cette loi climat résilience avec ce
texte l'ambition affichée de mettre un
terme à un ensemble de pratiques
incompatibles avec nos ambitions
climatiques la fin de l'étalement urbain
sans fin l'interdiction de la mise en
location des passoires thermiques
l'interdiction des vols domestiques pour
lesquels il existe une alternative moins
émettrices en co2 en moins de 2h30 la
régulation de la circulation des
voitures les plus polluantes dans nos
grandes villes
mais ne nous y trompons pas l'ampleur du
défi rappelé par le giec 30 août
solution nationale largement
insuffisante
la réponse ne pourrait être que
européenne et internationale la france
il prend toute sa part en montrant
l'exemple en entraînant ses partenaires
européens et en promouvant une action
internationale dans leurs relations
bilatérales comme multilatérale ce thème
jeudi en ouverture de mon propos il a
fait l'objet d'un examen minutieux et
approfondie dans nos commissions
respectives et en séance le mérite
premier en revient aux présidents de
commission et aux rapporteurs qui ont
réalisé un travail remarquable
remarquable et remarqué dans un souci
réel des coûte même si nous ne
partageons pas bien évidemment toutes
les conclusions et propositions
auxquelles ils ont pu arriver est arrivé
mais c'est aussi cela la force de la
démocratie que de pouvoir confronter
dans un climat apaisé points de vues et
propositions
alors oui nous ne partageons pas toutes
les options retenues par le sénat
considérant qu'elles ne sont pas les
plus à même de répondre aux enjeux qui
sont face à nous nous pourrions ainsi
parlé du refus du sénat de basculer vers
le oui tubes des ambiguïtés manifeste de
la majorité sénatoriale
dès lors qu'on parle d'énergie
renouvelable décarbonés d'un manque de
volonté pas tentons mettre en place les
zones à faibles émissions de la baisse
de tva à 5 5% pour les transports
collectifs de voyageurs alors que chacun
sait bien que le réel sujet n'est pas là
certains sujets liés à l'artifice
issia le sillon des sols où l'on mesure
que les contradictions sont nombreuses
la question des engrais azotés et bien
évidemment le fameux article 32
nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur tout et
nous avons à l'occasion d'amendements
fait entendre que nous pouvions tendre
vers davantage de volontarisme
ces amendements ils ont connu des
fortunes diverses mais je tiens
néanmoins salué la volonté des
rapporteurs d'expliquer encore et encore
sans dogmatisme aucun le pourquoi des
positions retenu dans le cas des avis
défavorables que nous avons entendu même
si nous ne l'avons pas toujours compris
nombre de collègues à droite et à gauche
de notre hémicycle on regrettait le
manque d'ambition du texte
bien au contraire ce projet de loi il se
fonde sur la confiance envers nos
concitoyens et sur la responsabilisation
des acteurs de la société
ces éléments ce sont les préalables de
l'appropriation des enjeux écologiques
par l'ensemble de la société
avec ce texte nous faisons le pari du
bon sens des français
toute une série de dispositifs les
concerne en tant que consommateurs
usagers de la route propriétaires de
logements clients de la restauration
collective dirigeants d'entreprises les
mécanismes d'incitation
d'expérimentation d'éducation et de
formation vise à ce que leur
comportement évolue progressivement vers
un plus grand respect de l'environnement
la responsabilisation des acteurs est la
conséquence de l'architecturé du projet
de loi dans tous les secteurs envisagés
par les thématiques du projet les
citoyens les acteurs économiques et
sociaux ont une feuille de route de
décarbonation soit sous forme de mesures
contraignantes et d'application dès la
promulgation de la loi soit après
expérimentation
chacun connaît donc les objectifs à
atteindre même si pour une large partie
d'entre eux les modalités sont encore à
débattre
la volonté politique portée par le
projet est très clairement exprimée elle
concilier écologie social et économie de
manière pragmatique afin de répondre
défis cruciaux de notre temps
députés et sénateurs connaissent
désormais le chemin à suivre pour
atteindre les objectifs que nous savons
commun et parce que nous sommes ne
sommes pas d'accord sur tout mais que
nous reconnaissons la qualité du travail
accompli et certaines ouvertures qui ont
pu être faites
le groupe rdi s'abstiendra sur le texte
je vous remercie
merci
je n'ai la parole entre collègues ory
cabanel pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre
chers collègues des conclusions du pré
rapport du giec sont d'une grande clarté
nos niveaux actuels d'adaptation seront
insuffisants pour contrer les menaces
événements extrêmes stress hydrique
maladie déclin des cultures de base et
de la valeur nutritionnelle des aliments
il souligne que l'humanité ne pourra pas
se remettre d'un changement climatique
majeur même s'il conçoit que ce constat
n'est pas inéluctable
il est encore possible de transformer
radicalement des comportements à tous
les niveaux individus communauté
entreprises institutions et
gouvernements
mais avons-nous le même niveau de
lecture de ces données
faisons-nous confiance à nos experts
nous avons depuis des mois reçu de très
nombreuses sollicitations sur ce projet
de loi
l'adhésion n'est pas là les résistances
sont fortes
pourtant une part croissante de nos
concitoyens prendre toute la mesure de
l'ampleur du défi
j'entends et je souscris aux arguments
sur lesquels la france ne peut à elle
seule assumer la charge de la lutte
contre le changement climatique et se
placer systématiquement situation de
subir la concurrence déloyale car de
l'économie dépend également notre survie
je le dis souvent dans cet hémicycle
l'échelle européenne doit être
pleinement mobilisés et privilégiées
mais la france doit prendre ses
responsabilités
c'était le sens des amendements
symbolique qui ont été votées en
préambule de nos débats notre rôle
premier en tant qu'élus et de
sensibiliser de convaincre et
d'accompagner pour déclencher
l'acceptation sociale car la loi ne peut
pas tout et elle n'est pas son rôle
le taux d'abstention lors des élections
départementales et régionales démontre
que l'adhésion à nos projets politiques
n'est pas acquise
les démarche vertueuse doivent être tant
qu encourager les dispositions du projet
de loi relative à l'amélioration de
l'information de consommateurs sont
bienvenus l'existence de pratiques
commerciales trompeuses en matière
environnemental provoqué l'intérêt des
citoyens se tournent davantage vers les
biens et services les plus respectueux
de la
demain l'encadrement de la publicité
deviendrait alors superflu dès lors que
le consommateur se rien trop
spontanément vers de tels produits
quant au transfert du au préfet du
pouvoir de police en matière de
publicité nous sommes satisfaits car de
nombreuses communes rurales ne pouvait
assumer cette charge l'accompagnement
des ménages modestes mais aussi des
classes moyennes en matière de transport
est également primordiale un contest
d'extension des restrictions à la
circulation
le sénat a fait oeuvre utile sur ce
titre par la mise en place d'un prêt à
taux zéro pour l'acquisition de
véhicules et de poids lourds peu
polluant de la tva à 5,5 pour les
billets de train ou encore
l'instauration d'un dispositif de
fixation d'un prix plancher pour
certains billets d'avion le titre
relatif au logement constitue notre plus
grande déception
la massification de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments est compromise
les dates retenues pour qualifié
d'indécente les passoires énergétiques
ne permettront pas de suivre la
trajectoire vers l'objectif de disposer
d'un parc de logements aux normes bbc en
demie de 50 et donc d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone au niveau de
l'agriculture il faut temporiser
si elle représente un quart de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
constitue également on pouvait centrale
par la captation du dioxyde de carbone
par le sol or il ne peut y avoir de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
sans les agriculteurs
je tient ainsi à saluer toutes les
mesures destinées à valoriser les
produits locaux durables et de qualité
renforcée par le sénat
mais l'urgence est avant tout de
récompenser les bonnes pratiques et
d'assurer le partage de la valeur et
donc le revenu des agriculteurs
sans quoi les index les investissements
de ces derniers pour l'agroécologie
risque de les pénaliser
je me réjouis de l'adoption de
l'amendement de ceux de monsieur franck
montaugé avec qui j'ai beaucoup
travaillé à ce sujet inscrivant dans la
loi la reconnaissance et la valorisation
des externalités positives de
l'agriculture notamment en matière de
services environnementaux et
d'aménagement du territoire
dans un texte qui comprend un titre
entier dédié à l'artificialisation des
sols
je regrette que la protection des terres
agricoles n'est pas été approfondies
j'avais déposé un amendement déclaré
irrecevable aux tic l'article 40 de la
constitution pour sacraliser la vocation
agricole était retombé
efi sied à ce titre des deux publics au
local nationale voire européenne
il vient tout simplement à ce qu'une
étude de terrain soient menées par le
département où le pci pour saisir
l'opportunité d'un périmètre de
protection des espaces agricoles et
périurbain ben vous cautionnez donc
collectivement que les terres agricoles
par exemple irriguées grâce à des
financements publics soit urbanisées je
ne comprends pas cette contradiction
tout le monde est d'accord pour défendre
l'agriculture mais personne pour graver
dans le marbre la protection durable des
terres agricoles ce qui concerne le
droit pénal de l'environnement le
gouvernement est passé à côté de la
réforme d'ampleur qui aurait dû aboutir
à sa simplification et ainsi à sa pleine
fx efficacité effectivité pardon le
choix était d'opérer par petites touches
de complexité supplémentaire sans créer
comme le recommande et de nombreux
juristes un véritable délit de mise en
danger de la vie ronnement est un délit
généré visant à sanctionner l'ensemble
des atteintes à l'environnement
le caractère durable de ces atteintes
exigé par les articles 67 et 68 du
projet de loi rend ces délits
inapplicable quant à la reconnaissance
de l'ecosite au niveau international
nous serons vigilants si nos idéaux de
se conforment se confrontent réalité
d'une économie mondialisée
ne laissons pas cette dernière les
briser définitivement la solution est
sans nul doute dans les concertations le
compromis démocratique malgré les
critiques acerbes qui ont été soulevés
ici et là l'expérience de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat doit être
étudiée et perfectionner cela n'enlèvera
en rien la légitimité de la démocratie
représentative bien au contraire elle la
confortera dans ce cas là le clip de
plus noble la représentation de
l'intérêt général
c'est certes une méthode complexe mais
les pros mais primordial de la
développer
car in fine et ses l'acceptabilité qui
est visé je regrette que les limites de
l'exercice n'est pas été fixé dès le
départ il était illusoire de faire
croire aux participants que toutes les
préconisations serait suivie à
et à saigner le débat parlementaire est
essentielle au processus
c'est générer des frustrations pour
conclure après ces deux semaines de
débats il me vient surtout à l'esprit un
dessin de zac bigors de 2017 ou l'un des
points guen affirme c'était mieux avant
lorsque l'autre lui demande de cannes
il lui répond quand je croyais que ce
serait mieux après mes chers collègues
pour que le monde ne soit mieux après
les efforts doivent être engagées dès
maintenant cette loi manque d'audace et
d'ambition et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je m'abstiendrai comme la
majorité de mon groupe
l'avenir appartient aux femmes et aux
hommes qui doivent assumer leur choix
ils n'ont pas été à la hauteur des
enjeux
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
venait à part l'autre collègue fabien
gay pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et kolo gist vous
avez la parole vous chers collègues
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il est déjà minuit
pour notre planète
l'humain et le vivant le vieux monde est
en train de s'écrouler la planète se
dégrade chaque jour de façon
irrémédiable
les espèces disparaissent par centaines
chaque année des populations entières
voire leur habitat en danger voire
dévasté et malgré cela nous regardons
ailleurs les catastrophes climatiques ne
sont plus des phénomènes isolés lointain
elle nous touche plus vite plus fort et
plus souvent mais nous continuons
regarder ailleurs
selon les experts du giec lorsque les
enfants nés cette année auront trente
ans le monde sera déjà irrémédiablement
dégradé soumis aux pénuries d'eau aux
exode à la malnutrition et à
l'extinction d'espèces en 2050 que
diront nos enfants et petits-enfants de
nous et de notre action et une action
climatique pardonnez moi alors que nous
savions et que nous n'avons rien fait ou
si peu nous refusons d'accepter le
changement vital qui s'imposent à nous
changement de mode de pensée de mode de
vie et surtout de ce système capitaliste
qui épuise l'humain le vivent les
ressources et la planète au profit de
quelques-uns et au détriment du plus
grand nombre
à la place on nous dit que le chemin est
long qu'il faut maintenir nos efforts
qui ressemblent à des petits sparadraps
qu'on utiliserait pour arrêter une
hémorragie massive
pourtant nous sommes la dernière
génération de femmes et hommes
politiques à pouvoir agir avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard pour les limites
planétaires pour certaines déjà dépassé
al'inverse projet de loi n'est pas à la
hauteur et il est même déjà obsolète
il est minuit et quart et en cette heure
tardive comme toujours vous n'avez pas
voulu écouter que vous même et vos peurs
d'une rupture radicale pourtant
nécessaire vous ignorez celles et ceux
qui se mobilisent les associations les
syndicats la jeunesse et même les
citoyennes et les citoyens la convention
citoyenne pour le climat que vous aviez
missionné les propositions qu'ils ont
construites il mettant du temps
de la réflexion de l'énergie mais aussi
de l'espoir
vous les aviez piétiner avec ce projet
de loi le mot d'ordre des débats sur ce
texte
c'est l évitement nous avons échangé des
heures sur l'agriculture pourtant vous
avez réussi l'exploit d'éviter les
sujets sur le revenu paysan et la pac au
niveau de la pac
le régime qui rend possible
l'utilisation des pesticides sera
rétribué au même montant que
l'agriculture biologique la suppression
des aides au maintien en agriculture
biologique ne sera pas compensée et les
aides au développement des protéines
végétales ne seront pas suffisantes pour
mettre fin aux importations de soja
destiné à l'alimentation des élevages
industriels
et que dire enfin de l'attentisme
interminable face au fléau des engrais
azotés
nous avons discuté des heures sur les
repas bio ou végétariens alors que se
multiplient les accords de libre-échange
mortifère est responsable de
l'augmentation du trafic de marchandises
de la déforestation du dumping social et
écologique mais voulait m'emmener sans
sourciller éviter une fois encore de
vous confronter à cette question ensuite
vous avez évité de prendre en compte les
engagements internationaux de la france
avec l'objectif de diminution de 40 % de
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'ici à 2030 alors même que l'union
européenne s'est récemment récemment
engagé à les diminuer de 55 % à cet
horizon afin d'atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050
certes des amendements visant à
réhausser l'ambition générale du projet
de loi les faisant passer d'une
réduction de 40 à 55 % d'émissions de
co2 d'ici 2030 ont été adoptés toutefois
selon le haut conseil pour le climat ce
texte n'engage aucun changement
structurel nécessaire une proportion
élevée de ces dispositions voit sa
portée réduite par un prix de périmètre
d'application limité
le constat est donc sans appel en l'état
des mesures prises la france n'atteindra
pas ses objectifs
de la même manière nous nous sommes émus
des problématiques de partage des usages
de l'eau car nous savons que le stress
hydrique est une donnée incontournable
et dans le même temps
le gouvernement a accepté voire
orchestré la privatisation de l'eau
potable en france avec la sphère suez
veolia concernant les entreprises et les
banques le gouvernement et la majorité
sénatoriale reste dans le déni pourtant
un rapport des amis de la terre et
d'oxfam documente l'absence d'engagement
des établissements bancaires dans la
transition énergétique
pire ils soutiennent à hauteur de 100
milliards de dollars de financement les
entreprises actives dans les énergies
fossiles
il n'y a rien dans ce texte pour les
contraindre vers la décarbonation leurs
activités et enfin et surtout vous avez
invité un élément fondamental la justice
sociale alors que les inégalités
explosent
vous ignorez toujours les plus précaires
ceux qui seront les plus touchés par les
crises à venir
tout le monde attend que nous mêlions
justice climatique et justice sociale
car nos concitoyens se soucient de
l'état de la planète
tout le monde aimerait pouvoir la
préserver et la transition doit être
accessible à toutes et tous l'évitement
donc du début à la fin
en déclarant même nos amendements
irrecevable du coup aucun débat sur le
travail le partage du temps de travail
un rien sur le partage de la valeur
ajoutée dans l'agro alimentaire en
particulier refus de taxer les
transactions financières de mettre les
moyens pour combattre la déforestation
importés en termes de logement seuls des
objectifs à très long terme alors que la
rénovation des bâtiments est fondamental
a rien sur le service public ferroviaire
et les trains d'équilibré du territoire
et la liste est encore longue il faut
reconnaître que le sénat sur certains
points à améliorer le texte initial en
matière de publicité pour les véhicules
polluants d'intégration des impacts
sociaux et du respect des droits humains
dans l'affichage environnemental de tva
réduite sur les billets de trains à 5,5
d'exclusion d'entreprises qui ne
satisfont pas l'obligation d'établir un
plan de vigilance de certains marchés
cependant certains reculs sont pour nous
inacceptable comme son l'essonne à
faibles émissions
alors que les morts prématurées liés à
la pollution de l'air ne sont plus
contestable que dire encore de la
gestion des installations fret qui
pourront être externalisées attend un
peu plus la casse de sf réseau
il n'est plus possible de croire que
sans remise en cause du dogme de la
concurrence libre et non faussée ainsi
que de l'idée d'un monde sans limites
nous puissions répondre aux enjeux
climatiques et environnementaux oui un
texte qui porte l'ambition d'un
changement de société doit mettre au
coeur du débat
les biens communs et le service public
nous avons réussi l'exploit de parler
d'énergie pendant des heures alors qu'en
même temps vous vous apprêtez à
démanteler privatiser une partie des
activités d'edf
pour conclure il est déjà minuit 30 pour
la planète
votre coup de com viger a tout changé
pour finalement que rien ne change
c'est pourquoi nous voterons pondre ce
texte je vous remercie
merci va t'en donner la parole aux
présidents jean françois longeot pour le
groupe de l'union centriste le président
monsieur le président vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président madame un ministre mes chers
collègues je tiens a commencé ses
explications de vote par des
remerciements remerciements envers les
membres de la commission d'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable pour leur engagement et
particulièrement ses rapporteurs
rapporteur qui n'ont pas ménagé leurs
efforts ces derniers mois je remercie
également les rapporteurs des
différentes commissions pour le travail
collectif complémentaires et en bonne
intelligence
remerciements envers les services de la
commission que j'ai l'honneur de
présider pour leur dévouement envers la
direction de la séance pour son précieux
appui ainsi que les galas collaborateurs
de groupe pour leurs conseils avisés
madame la ministre nous voilà ainsi à la
fin du marathon sénatoriales marathon
qui a commencé pour vous il ya bien
longtemps
depuis la présentation en juin dernier
des propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat dont le présent
projet de loi est la traduction
législative
à cet égard permettez-moi une peur une
première parenthèse si la convention
citoyens aient démontré que certaines
formes de démocratie directe ou
participative pouvait trouver une place
dans la vème république
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
n'a jamais eu vocation à se substituer
aux pouvoirs législatifs
et le parlement a ainsi démontré qu'il
n'abandonnerait pas son pouvoir de
proposition et son droit d'amendement
[Applaudissements]
donc en moins que le texte qui nous
arrivait à l'assemblée nationale nous
semblait manquer d'ambition et de
pragmatisme nous doutions même de son
effet climatique
quand il passait à côté de nos
engagements européens réhaussé en ds en
décembre dernier nous regrettions
également un projet de loi
paradoxalement bavard sur des points de
détail et qui passait sous silence des
secteurs essentiels dans la réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mais ces fameuses humblement l'était
également dans les travaux de la
convention citoyenne ce qui a été
confirmé par le rapport blanchard tyrol
si le si les recommandations de la
convention citoyenne ne suffisent pas à
atteindre l'objectif de réduction des
émissions c'est normalement
notamment parce qu'elle n'aborde pas les
questions centrales que sont le mix
électrique est la tarification du
carbone
ainsi il est logique que le présent
projet de loi reflète ses faiblesses
originelles
nous pourrons donc dès lors nous pencher
d'autant que nous le souhaitons sur la
question des échantillons commerciaux
des avions publicitaire vous demandez
pléthore de rapport je crois pour ma
part qu'il est temps d'agir
agir sur les principaux leviers qui nous
permettront de rehausser l'effet
climatique du projet de loi et plus
généralement d'engager notre pays sur la
voie de la neutralité carbone
dans cette optique je tiens à saluer les
nombreux rapports du sénat qui
s'articule autour de trois ambitions
premièrement la suppression des angles
morts du texte je salue l'inscription
dans la loi de l'objectif de doublement
des part modale du fret ferroviaire et
fluvial est la concrétisation de cette
ambition ou via la diminution de la tva
à 5,5 sur les billets de train
je salue également l'impulsion bienvenue
pour nos forêts afin d'optimiser leur
rôle de puits carbone quand on sait que
ces derniers absorbent chaque année en
france +11 % de nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre deuxièmement en
conciliant économie écologie et justice
sociale
je pense à la logique selon laquelle les
aides à la rénovation énergétique
doivent davantage être attribué en
fonction des revenus et non seulement de
la performance de la rénovation
encore au rétablissement du taux de tva
5,5 sur les travaux de rénovation
énergétique d'un logement social la
rénovation des bâtiments s'illustre
selon moi illustre selon moi le chemin
heureux de la transition écologique et
les opportunités davantage que les
menaces qu'elle soulève
en créant des emplois emplois non
délocalisables
rudy jean les émissions polluantes et en
améliorant la santé des populations
troisièmement nous avons défendu une
écologie territoriales une écologie
pragmatique
nous avons choisi de confier la prise de
décision en priorité aux collectivités
territoriales car nous savons les élus
locaux responsables en déclinant au
niveau des scot l'objectif de zéro
artificialisation net des sols en
prévoyant un droit d'option pour les 200
communes littorales concernées par le
recul du trait de côte ou encore en
dynamisant la politique alimentaire
territoriales mes chers collègues le
sénat a donc démontré démontré son
ambition écologique et qu'il n'était pas
une assemblée un garde qui passait à
côté des grands défis de son temps
nous avons même démontré par l'adoption
d'un amendement portant article
additionnel avant l'article 1er à notre
ambition commune et transpartisane
d'aller au bout des engagements
climatiques de la france si
effectivement notre pays ne représente
qu'un pour cent de la population
mondiale et n'aura qu'une incidence
directe faible dans la lutte conte la
transition écologique
j'en suis convaincu elle peut avoir une
influence indirecte considérable comme
le disait victor hugo que ce que paris
conseil l'europe le med-it ce que paris
commence l'europe le continue en amont
de la co 26 et de la présidence
française de l'union européenne
notre pays peut donner une impulsion
climatique ambitieuse à ses partenaires
européens impulsion qui se
retrouveraient et demain dans les
accords commerciaux par exemple la
tarification carbone c'est tout l'enjeu
de cet amendement qui réaffirme les
engagements climatiques européens et
internationaux de la france
un amendement déposé par la plupart des
groupes politiques du sénat
à commencer par mon groupe union
centriste plus globalement le groupe
union centriste a pris toute sa part
dans ces débats nous nous réjouissons
d'avoir fait adopter en séance des
amendements d'important
ainsi avons nous fait entrer dans le
code minier la notion de gestion minière
durable acté la création d'un schéma
directeur des itinéraires cyclables
inscrire le principe d'une modulation de
l'éco taxe pour les poids lourds à
faibles émissions ou encore fait adopter
un principe de dérogation règles de
commandes publiques pour développer la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics fort de ses apports concrets le
groupe union centriste
votre rat donc en faveur de ce projet
projet de loi tel amendé par notre haute
assemblée madame ligne je vous le dis
avec une certaine solennité
maintenant nous souhaitons vraiment que
l'âme commission mixte paritaire puisse
être conclusive
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président vous avez la parole à notre
collègue joël bigot pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
avec la parole mon cher collègue
si le président madame la ministre
mesdames messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues nous voici au bout de ce
marathon législatif qui s'est déroulée à
un rythme effréné
nous avions en tout et pour tout 15
jours pour changer la donne de ce projet
de loi est rehaussé ses ambitions la
voix fut étroite pour notre groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
même alliés sur bon nombre de sujets à
la gauche de cet hémicycle
d'un côté la majorité présidentielle et
le gouvernement qui persistent à
amoindrir voir dénaturer les travaux
éclairé de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat de l'autre une droite
sénatoriale qui a bien tenté de se
verdir sans y parvenir concrètement arc
bouté sur un savant discours construit
autour de l'écologie punitive
belle trouvaille rhétorique pour
justifier l'immobilisme
pourtant mes chers collègues le contexte
dans lequel se sont déroulées nos débats
auraient dû nous convaincre de la
responsabilité écologique qui nous
incombe la canicule à paris
les dérèglements climatiques récurrents
les fuites d'un nouveau rapport du giec
anticipant des retombées cataclysmique
ou encore le rapport le rapport tyrol
blanchard qui pointe la menace
existentielle que fait peser le
réchauffement
les signes annonciateurs sont déjà là et
nous continuons disserter sur
l'autorégulation des agents économiques
à multiplier les expérimentations sans
définir de trajectoire claire à ne pas
entendre ce que nous disent les citoyens
formés par les meilleurs experts que
compte notre pays
à force de surplace de communication
variablement devant les conséquences
réelles du changement climatique
devant ce temps que nous laissons filer
nous construisons des usines à gaz
organisons notre propre impuissance avec
le démantèlement d'edf par exemple au
lieu de s'attaquer vraiment à la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre
comment voulons-nous revivifier notre
démocratie
lorsque nous nous condamnons à
l'inaction lorsque le gouvernement
abaisse sa stratégie nationale bas
carbone
lorsque nous nous n'assumons pas notre
leadership écologique qui s'était
manifestée lors du précédent quinquennat
avec les accords de paris et pourtant
voilà le ferment d'une nouvelle lucie
universalisme français du 21e siècle
l'écologie
articulée à la justice sociale le giec
nous y invite
nous avons besoin d'une transformation
radicale des processus et des
comportements à tous les niveaux
individus communauté entreprises
institutions et gouvernements nous
devons redéfinir notre mode de vie et de
consommation
ce projet de loi y participent t-il
malheureusement non outreau fébrilement
il ne s'agit pas d'être alarmiste mais
réaliste mes chers collègues nous ne
pouvons que regretter que le sénat dans
sa majorité n'est pas encore terminé sa
mue écologique
trop de vieux réflexes trop de
certitudes nous confine encore à
l'insécurité écologique
si bien que toute une jeunesse touché
par la faiblesse générale de nos débats
en appel aujourd'hui à ce que l'ensemble
de la classe politique soient formés aux
enjeux climatiques
tout comme le furent les 150 citoyens
tirés au sort pour notre part malgré le
gros travail d'amendements que nous
avons réalisés nous n'avons pas réussi à
convaincre la majorité sénatoriale du
mouvement à faire pour corriger ce
projet de loi d'affichage parcellaire et
insuffisant comparé à nos objectifs pour
rester en deçà de 1 degré 5
nous pouvons tout de même nous réjouir
de l'adoption de quelques unes de nos
propositions que nous sommons depuis
bientôt cinq ans la patience a du bon je
pense à quelques exemples à
l'introduction de critères sociaux dans
l'affichage environnemental au
renforcement du contrôle des engagements
publicitaires à l'introduction des
objectifs de développement durable dans
les principes de l'achat public aux
mesures relatives à la pollution des
sols
suite aux propositions de notre
commission d' enquête menée par gisèle
jourda ou encore à celle portée par
nicole bonnefoy sur le régime des
catastrophes naturelles sur le titre iii
nous avons également obtenu quelques
avancées pour la création d'un prêt à
taux zéro automobile pour alléger le
reste à charge des ménages modestes
la réduction du taux de tva pour le
transport ferroviaire des voyageurs
à noter toujours le vote favorable de
notre haute assemblée sur la
reconnaissance c'est ça effet signalé
parle notre collègue henri cabanel cher
à notre collègue franck montaugé dans le
code rural des externalités positives de
l'agriculture et le développement des
services environnementaux et
d'aménagement des territoires ruraux
nous considérons qu'il s'agit là d'une
avancée très importante tout comme
l'introduction dans notre politique en
faveur de la
les cultures et l'alimentation de la
nécessité de préserver nos agriculteurs
de la concurrence déloyale de produits
importés ne respectant pas les normes
imposées par la réglementation
européenne
toutefois il est à craindre au regard
des avis défavorable du gouvernement que
ces quelques acquis ne résisteront pas à
la commission mixte paritaire
par ailleurs nos critiques sur l'absence
de justice sociale demeure tout aussi
fondé deux semaines après notre examen
rien sur la résidence sociale que ce
projet de loi aurait dû prévoir
n'oublions pas que le mouvement des
gilet jaune est issu de l'augmentation
de la taxe carbone il avait conduit au
gel de la trajectoire de la contribution
carbone en 2010 900 évaluation des
impacts sociaux des mesures prises en
termes de pouvoir d'achat d'emploi la
transition écologique condamnée à
échouer faute d'acceptabilité sociale
avis défavorable quant à nos
propositions pour une garantie à
l'emploi vert pour permettre la
conversion écologique de notre modèle
économique plutôt que de reculer face au
e-commerce et favoriser la casse sociale
et environnementale ni et la dimension
solidaire de la transition écologique ne
fera que renforcer les inégalités face
au réchauffement climatique
je terminerai par une illustration très
concrète de nos débats et qu'ils les
montrent nos difficultés en tant
qu'opposition à faire valoir
le réalisme écologique d'un côté le
gouvernement refuse d'élargir
l'interdiction pour les trajets de moins
de 2h30 prévu à l'article 36 pour les
vols en jet privé je cite madame wargon
car cela remettrait en cause la liberté
d'aller et venir ne touchons surtout pas
aux ultra privilégiés quand il s'agit de
défendre l'intérêt général et nos
enfants
de l'autre la grotte de cet hémicycle
tout en repoussant l'interdiction de
location des logements classés f créer
un nouveau congé pour travaux pour
rénovation énergétique ce n'est pas une
caricature du coût des logements qui
permet d'expulser plus facilement
allocataires sous motif de rénovation
des bâtiments
voilà l'écueil politique des paradoxes
de la communication l'énergie auquel
nous sommes confrontés pour enclencher
la transition écologique et solidaire
si le projet de loi contient des petits
pas il conte il constitue un terrible
aveu d'un puits
climatique est un véritable échec pour
le gouvernement alors que la convention
citoyenne pour le climat c'est une très
belle réussite démocratique
nous ne pouvons que regretter la
faiblesse de sa traduction législative
pour toutes ces raisons nous voterons
contre le texte qui nous est proposé je
vois merci merci la parole est à notre
collègue stéphane ravier en les
sénateurs de figurant sur la liste aucun
groupe
il a trois minutes
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la mise mais chers
collègues saint-exupéry disait que nous
empruntions la terre à nos enfants s'ils
parlaient assurément dans la nature il
parlait surtout de la cité tout entière
face aux intérêts court termiste de
quelques-uns il nous invite à voir la
transmission dans le temps long et à
protéger ce qui fait notre bien commun
s'il écologique nous concerne tous la
vague notion de climat et résilience en
titre de ce projet de loi annoncé déjà
un contenu conforme un prêt-à-penser
bien éloignée d'une clairvoyance
écologique nouvelle confondre écologie
et climat s'est déjà laissé libre cours
à l'idéologie qui fait de la taxation
l'alpha et l'oméga d'un écologisme aussi
punitif qu'inefficace ce projet de loi
reflète le en même temps progressiste
friands de contradictions ce texte se
contente de mesures néfastes ou de
surface je pense en particulier aux
éoliennes véritable totem sacré de
l'écolo boboïsme elle pour l'une au sol
avec des milliers de mètres cubes de
béton elle tu n'oses oiseaux et font
fuir la faune elles ont un bilan carbone
déplorable et le ruiner des milieux de
vie elle défigure des contours poétiques
de nos paysages
dans les bouches du rhône le projet
d'implantation de ces horreurs au pied
de la merveilleuse femme victoire si
chère à sézanne et à tous les amoureux
de ce que la nature nous a offert de
plus beau est un véritable crime avec
les parcs éoliens et solaires terrestre
ou offshore vous industrialisés vous
défigurer le paysage et vous généralisez
le retour aux centrales à gaz et à
charbon pour un bilan écologique négatif
il est donc important d'autoriser les
maires à refuser l'implantation
d'éoliennes sur leur commune c'est ce
que le sénat dans sa grande sagesse a
fait nous ne pouvons que nous en réjouir
le sénat a aussi supprimé la notion de
crime déco side qui aurait pu se
retourner contre vous quand votre
chantier de forage d'éoliennes offshore
en baie de saint brieuc madame la
ministre
un autre totem exubérant les repas
végétariens hebdomadaire dans les
cantines dont la généralisation a été
supprimée par le sénat
le syndicat culture viande nous explique
que 70% du poulet servi dans les
cantines est importé de l'étranger
mais pour vous tant pis si nos écoliers
sont nourris avec de la vie
en brésil yens l'important c'est qu'ils
mangent un menu végétarien par semaine
sans nouveauté on constate surtout à
quel point la question cruciale de
l'environnement est instrumentalisée par
des idéologues qui parle de planter des
arbres mais qui s'acharnent surtout à
couper nos racines pour oeuvrer en
faveur de l'environnement nous devons
protéger nos producteurs locaux
favoriser les circuits courts revoir
notre place dans la mondialisation
l'écologie ne s'impose pas selon l'écho
d'un exercice bureaucratique cette
responsabilité s'exerce localement dans
le quotidien de chacun
je crois d'ailleurs qu'il ya encore un
bon sens locale puisque je ne vois
toujours pas d'éoliennes de 150 m dans
le jardin du luxembourg ni de panneaux
solaires sur le toit du sénat comme
alternative à la mondialisation
écologiquement désastreuse nous
proposons une écologie de la vie
enraciné local incitatives respectueuse
de l'homme et de l'intégrité notamment
visuel de la biodiversité en vue d'y
contribuer je vous autorise les
modifications positives apportées par
les sénateurs
pourtant la parents les élus locaux sur
ce projet de loi
merci la parole va être à notre collègue
didier mandelli pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
lever la parole monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
nous étions réunis ici même le 14 juin
dernier pour débuter l'examen de ce
projet de loi
j'avais exprimé au nom de mon groupe
notre regret quand on manque d'ambition
de ce texte au regard de la volonté
affichée et des engagements pris par le
président de la république notamment
devant la convention citoyenne pour le
climat et par le décalage avec le projet
de loi de révision constitutionnelle qui
vise à placer au plus haut la question
environnementale avec d'autres groupes
nous avons rédigé et voter un amendement
qui impose à la france de respecter la
trajectoire définie par les accords de
paris et la future répartition des
efforts négocier au niveau européen en
termes d'émissions de co2 il s'agissait
tout simplement de rappeler au
gouvernement ses obligations alors que
de nombreux observateurs et acteurs au
conseil pour le climat ong
parlementaires s'inquiètent plusieurs
milliers d'amendements et des dizaines
d'heures de débats plus tard force est
de constater que les échanges ont été
riches que chacun a pu défendre avec
conviction souvent avec sensibilité
parfois et beaucoup de sobriété ses
positions cela sans sombrer dans la
caricature où les clichés habituels dans
ce genre de circonstance et pour une
raison simple parce qu'individuellement
et collectivement nous partageons une
certitude désormais celle de l'urgence
d'agir pour le climat bien sûr la france
ne règle pas à elle seule cette question
essentielle pour nous mêmes et nos
enfants mais elle peut et doit y
contribuer en tant que grande puissance
et parce qu'elle représente dans le
concert international nation ce projet
de loi nous permet d'apporter une touche
supplémentaire le sénat sous l'impulsion
des deux commissions principalement
investi l'aménagement du territoire et
développement durable et affaires
économiques dont je salue les présidents
jean françois longeot et sophie primas
agrément bonifier ce texte avec le sens
des responsabilités qui caractérise la
haute assemblée nous nous sommes
imprégnés de ce texte
décortiquer le moindre mot chaque
article chaque titre permettez moi de
saluer à ce stade le travail fourni par
les différents rapporteurs qui ont su
trouver un équilibre parfois subtils sur
de nombreux sujets entre raison
ambitions et tentation de suppression
les nombreuses auditions et contribution
les passages en commission ont nécessité
un fort investissement des rapporteurs
bien sûr et je les remercie au nom de
chacun d'entre nous je remercie
également les administrateurs pour leur
engagement leur compétence reconnue le
au delà de cette enceinte sont à nouveau
exercer de la plus belle des manières
certains considèrent qu on s'en doute
que nous ne sommes pas allés assez loin
et où assez vite d'autres penseront le
contraire nous avons pu le vérifier à
l'occasion des débats et à l'instant
même au travers des différents orateurs
qui m'ont précédé
cela signifie sans doute que la voie
empruntée la bonne avec du bon sens et
du pragmatisme sans idéologie ni dogme
j'en veux pour preuve les avancées sur
tous les titres affichage
environnemental encadrement d
encadrement de la publicité
certification de tralee t carbone impact
des livraisons l'économie sociale et
solidaire commande publique cycle de vie
pollution des eaux et continuités
écologiques forêt éolien terrestre et en
mer hydroélectricité méthanisation t
icpe verdissement du parc poids lourds
tva à 5,5 sur le transport de voyageurs
ferroviaires compensation carbone sur
les rien transport de marchandises
véhicules particuliers entreprises vélo
zones faibles émissions recul du trait
de côte et reprotéger qualité de l'air
rénovation performante des bâtiments
pollution des sols catastrophes
naturelles restauration collective
produits locaux et de qualité
souveraineté alimentaire déforestation
importés cette liste n'est pas
exhaustive
elle illustre incontestablement
l'importante contribution des sénatrices
et des sénateurs
quels que soient leur groupe politique
d'origine où l'avait évoqué tous les
groupes ont eu des amendements adoptés
dans les quinze jours de débats en
réalité nous ne faisons qu accompagner
la prise de conscience et les
réalisations de tous les acteurs engagés
sur ce sujet associations entreprises
agriculteurs collectivités locales
fédérations syndicats professionnels
chaque jour qui passe apporte son lot de
nouvelles encourageantes
une économie que six qui se dirige à
grands pas vers la décarbonation le
glissement des énergies fossiles vers
les renouvelables
des investissements vertueuse et
responsable de façon irréversible les
enjeux climat sont désormais intégrés à
tous les niveaux de la société par
chacun de nos concitoyens je m'en
réjouis
engagé sur ces sujets depuis toujours à
titre personnel et sur le plan politique
je peux attester de cette évolution
rapide les positive
nous sommes lucides cependant il reste
beaucoup à faire pour modifier la
trajectoire mais nous sommes confiants
sur la capacité de l'homme à accélérer
le mouvement amorcé depuis plusieurs
années nous ne souhaitons pas céder au
catastrophisme ou au déclinisme de
certains parce que nous avons intimement
besoin d'une espérance avec un grand e
je crois en l'instinct de survie de
notre espèce nous serons ensemble
protéger le vivant faire preuve
d'altruisme en un mot j'ai foi en notre
hub humanité madame la ministre
vos collègues bérengère à barbe sur ma
6e djebbari emmanuelle wargon julien de
normandie qui se sont succédé sur ce bon
et vous même avait pu mesurer notre
implication sur ces textes et notre
volonté affichée à plusieurs reprises
d'aboutir à une cmp conclusive le
président longeole a évoqué tout à
l'heure qui intégrerait l'essentiel de
nos apports à ce texte que le groupe
l'est républicain
votre à cela constituerait un signal
fort à quelques encablures de la coop 26
de glasgow et de la présidence française
de l'union européenne
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole de notre
collègue pierre médevielle pour le
groupe les indépendants
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues ne fois de plus le sénat est
arrivé au bout d'un projet de loi xxl en
y apportant sa touche et territoriales
plus de 4200 amendement était discuté
des dizaines d'articles ajoutés ou
réécrit en commission et en séance
publique
nous avons réussi à inscrire ce texte
est dans le concret pour favoriser une
transition réaliste et qui dit vrai nous
tenons avec mon groupe a salué le
travail remarquable accompli par la
commission son président et le
rapporteur
si l'on en croit les seconds dîner des
adeptes de la décroissance
le gouvernement aurait déçu les
ambitions de la convention citoyenne
je pense plutôt que le politique a été
suffisamment pragmatiques pour ne pas
reprendre son filtre toutes les mesures
de bon sens où l'on élaboré par les 150
dans se plongeant dans les centaines de
pages du dispositif législatif un autre
diagnostic s'impose là bien pensants
c'est la bureaucratie ont trouvé de
nombreux terrains d'entente
il faut le dire clairement ce texte est
une mine d'or pour tous les
administrateurs convaincu que la
complexification des normes et
l'alourdissement des charges sont des
gages d'une action publique vertueuse
bien naïve qui croirait que de simples
citoyens qui se confronte tous les jours
administration tatillonne ont pu
élaborer des solutions si complexe et si
procédurière problèmes climatiques sans
l'aide bienveillante des fonctionnaires
de l'hôtel de roquelaure lui parti que
contient ce texte évoqué des sujets
aussi divers qu'un important lors des
discussions nous avons débattu de la
rénovation des bâtiments de l'écocide en
passant par les transports la publicité
ou les énergies et l'agriculture mais de
manière récurrente
nous avions l'impression de passer à
côté de sujets pourtant primordiaux
comment avoir un objectif ambitieux de
diminution des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre sans se pencher un peu plus
profondément sur le futur de notre mix
énergétique et en évoquant du bout des
lèvres la question du nucléaire
c'est pourtant d'une des clés du
problème de même d'autres sujets comme
l'hydrogène ou le transport fluvial
aurait mérité un examen plus approfondi
les sénateurs du groupe les indépendants
ont été vigilants ont déposé de nombreux
amendements que ce soit en commission en
séance publique dont beaucoup ont été
adoptés il s'insérer dans la vision
d'écologie libérale et pragmatique que
notre groupe défend depuis sa création
la dimension environnementale se marrent
inévitablement avec des dimensions
économique et sociale afin d'oeuvrer et
de réaliser une transition efficace
rapide et juste à la fois pour les
citoyens et les territoires nous avons
défendu une vision de l'agriculture
alliant rémunération suffisante et
impératifs écologiques
il faut absolument trouver un consensus
dans ce domaine arrêtons les sur
transposition et l'auto flagellation
sachant reconnaître que notre
agriculture est une des plus propres et
nos meilleurs du monde
si l'on écoute les intégristes en tout
genre nous finirons pas remporter
n'importe quoi pour notre alimentation
de même nous avons soutenu le
développement des bio liquide et
biocarburants ainsi que le stockage dans
le secteur des énergies renouvelables
autant de sujets essentiels pour
l'avenir de la france et de la planète
malgré la densité de ce texte j'aimerais
revenir sur quelques sujets majeurs dans
notre attention ne doit pas être
détournée la question du nucléaire n'a
été qu'effleuré nous pensons que cette
énergie est essentielle à notre bouquet
énergétique qu'elle sécurisé notre
approvisionnement et que la france de
continuer à innover dans ce domaine
le nucléaire c'est en appui aux
innovations des énergies renouvelables à
leur stockage à leur intégration dans
notre mix énergétique
la problématique du littoral qui m'est
chère a fait l'objet de discussions
intéressantes en tant que membre du
conservatoire du littoral
je veux redire son importance
extraordinaire où l'ensemble notre
territoire national
sa protection est notre devoir tant sa
place pour la préservation de la
biodiversité et les qui devrait espèce
est primordial le volet transport a été
un sujet de réflexion particulièrement
intense
arrêtons de pénaliser nos propres pme
dans le secteur du transport routier de
marchandises
il est important de leur donner le temps
nécessaire à la transition tout en les
accompagnant réellement notre transition
nous permettre de rester compétitif et
ne doit pas détruire nos emplois et
notre système économique
enfin la stratégie nationale de lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols
illustre le manque de réalisme que
traduit parfois ce texte et l'écart
entre l'objectif affiché et les moyens
déployés pour la terrasse
un seul français ne se réjouit que notre
pays c'est béton à vue d'oeil
mais aucun ne comprendrai non plus que
son logement ou son emploi sont soumis à
une application très stricte des règles
émises depuis paris sur ce sujet encore
le sénat a été force de proposition pour
assouplir la mise à niveau territoriale
de ces stratégies nationales
je crois que nous imaginons à peindre et
contraintes qui ce texte risque de faire
peser le développement de nos
territoires plus particulièrement ruraux
dans les années à venir surtout nous
risquons de leur imposer une double
peine d'une part nous contraindront les
territoires dans leur développement
d'autre part nous pénaliserons davantage
de territoire vertueux qui ont peu
artificialisés au cours des dernières
années
notre groupe a fait des propositions
afin d'apporter des solutions à ces
problèmes en matière de transition
écologique comme de nombreux autres
domaines
les solutions ne sont efficaces que si
elles sont territorialisées à ce sujet
nous aurons l'occasion au cours du
projet de loi 3ds d'approfondir le débat
sur la différenciation et la
décentralisation
le dérèglement climatique est une
réalité tous les jours sur nos
territoires sur le mien sur le vôtre
chaque saison se modifie les sécheresse
s'accentue depuis son diluviennes nous
devons nous adapter rapidement mais
cette adaptation ne se fera pas en
reculant et nous avons trouvé des
solutions ambitieuses audacieuse et
novatrice et n'auront de sens que si
nous le travaillons à l'échelle
européenne et mondiale ensuite le chemin
est encore long
le défi immense et n'ont pas d'autre
choix que de relever pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe les indépendants
vaudra à l'unanimité pour ce texte
poursuivra le travail de la transition
en espérant une cmp aussi complet titre
merci mon cher que l'oeil
madame la ministre les chers collègues
il va donc procéder dans les conditions
prévues par l'article 56 de notre
règlement au scrutin public sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi portant
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
et renforcement de la résilience face à
ces effets le scrutin va être ouvert
dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin donc clos
résultat du scrutin numéro 148 sur
l'ensemble du texte
compte tenu des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs au groupe
politique est notifiée à la présidence
nombre de votants 347 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 293 pour l'adoption
193 contre sens le sénat a donc adopté
je vais donner la parole maintenant à
barbara pour pili ministre de la
transition écologique
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs à ce
stade de l'examen du texte
je voulais d'abord saluer ceux qui en
ont été à l'initiative puisque celles et
ceux tout à fait puisque ce texte a été
précédée d'un exercice démocratique
inédit exercice démocratique très
certainement perfectible et dont nous
devrons tirer des leçons mais qui avait
le mérite d'essayer d'apporter une
réponse au désarroi d'un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens qui souhaitent
participer à l'exercice de la démocratie
que nous devons certainement chercher
tous à réinventer ses 150 citoyens
membres de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat ont déployé beaucoup d'énergie
ont pris du temps beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de week end qu'ils n'ont pas
passé dans leur famille beaucoup de
temps sur leur travail pour participer
de manière bénévole
ils ont apporté cette contribution est
cette contribution elle a permis
d'aboutir à un certain nombre de
décisions qui ont été prises et pas
seulement à ce texte de loi mais aussi à
ce texte de loi qui a été ensuite confié
à la représentation nationale
je crois que ce qui d'ailleurs dont je
faisais partie qui exprimait des doutes
qui a exprimé des inquiétudes par
rapport un conflit de légitimité qui
pourraient exister ou par rapport à une
opposition qui pourrait y avoir entre
leur travail et la démocratie
représentative je crois que tous ceux là
peuvent être rassurés
chacun a fait sa part du travail la
démocratie représentative a joué son
rôle que ce soit à l'assemblée nationale
ou au sénat
sur le fond je rappelle que ce texte
s'inscrit dans un ensemble beaucoup plus
vaste ce qui peut expliquer qu'un
certain nombre de sujets n'ai pas été
compris dans ce texte je rappelle que ce
texte il suit d'autres textes notamment
un ce texte sur les mobilités qui avait
fait l'objet d'assises un texte sur
l'économie circulaire sur la lutte
contre le gaspillage
un autre texte sur l'énergie aie sur le
climat ce texte s'inscrit également dans
un processus de relance de notre machine
économique à travers le plan de relance
qui a bénéficié aux entreprises qui a
bénéficié à tous les secteurs émetteurs
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre aux
filières que nous voulons faire émerger
nous avons 30 milliards sur ce plan de
relance qui ont été consacrés à la
transition écologique bref tout cela
fait partie d'un ensemble et le fait de
ne regarder que le texte en lui-même
forcément peut sembler frustrant puisque
effectivement tout n'est pas abordée là
puisque c'est abordés ailleurs
de la même manière notre politique
énergétique notre politique de
transition énergétique fait l'objet de
procédures
nous avons une programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie qui va
ensuite faire l'objet d'une loi qui sera
étudiée en 2023 ou 2024 j'ai un petit
doute
à l'instant où je vous parle mais donc
tout cela fait partie d'un processus
général mais par contre ce à quoi nous
avons fait très attention et je réponds
à certaines observations qui ont été
faites
c'est justement à éviter des erreurs du
passé les erreurs du passé ça a été trop
certainement de penser la transition
écologique dans dans son sillon sans
faire suffisamment attention aux
retombées que ça pouvait avoir que ce
soit sur les territoires que ce soit sur
nos concitoyens dans leur vie
quotidienne et ce texte justement c'est
un texte qui veut mettre l'écologie dans
la vie quotidienne des gens et apporter
des solutions à tout le monde pas une
mesure de ce texte par une mesure de la
transition écologique n'est pas
accompagnée d'une mesure
d'accompagnement justement notamment
vis-à-vis des personnes les plus en
difficulté enfin je tiens à saluer
le travail qui a été fait notamment par
les rapporteurs des deux commissions qui
ont travaillé par les présidents le
président et la présidente des deux
commissions qui ont principalement
travaillé sur ce sujet un travail qui a
été très fourni et que je tiens vraiment
à saluer il y a eu des échanges
il y a eu des dialogues et 7 salutations
républicaines n'empêche pas évidemment
qu'il ya des désaccords entre nous que
ces désaccords sont là un point quand
même me réjouit c'est que je n'ai
entendu sur aucun banc à une remise en
cause une remise en question de
l'urgence à agir pour la transition
écologique en général c'est un énorme
progrès il s'avère que ça fait 20 ans
que je travaille sur ces questions que
ça fait 20 ans que je suis engagé dans
l'écologie cette bascule est récente et
cette bascule est un point extrêmement
positif que je tiens à saluer très
fortement
ensuite il est plus facile et je crois
qu'on en sera tous d'accord de faire des
déclarations générales ou de faire un
amendement qui est un amendement qui
réussit à réunir tout le monde mais en
général quand on réussit à réunir tout
le monde sait que finalement ça n'est
pas très engageant donc faire un
amendement qui dit qu'on doit respecter
des règles c'est très bien et je le
salue simplement on voit que ça devient
plus difficile quand il s'agit de
rentrer dans le dur quand il s'agit de
rentrer dans la mise en application
et ceux qui disent que cette loi ou que
ce projet de loi est un projet de loi
qui est vide ou qui n'a pas beaucoup de
substance je vois que ils se heurtent
quand même à de très nombreuses
oppositions qui d'ailleurs dont on
considère que cette petite substance est
encore trop ce qui veut dire que quelque
part on doit être dans le vrai comme
comme disaient certains orateurs
nous avons des désaccords qui ont été
entérinés des désaccords importants
notamment sur des questions de fond sur
des points comme les aides et feu sur
l'artificialisation sur la continuité
écologique des cours d'eau sur les
renouvelables sur la publicité sur
l'écocide et d'autre ces points sont des
points sur lesquels je souhaite que
qu'ils puissent être revenu lors de la
cmp
nous verrons comment se passera cette
cmp mais il me semble que nous devons à
tous de garder une ambition très haute
pour ce texte
et c'est ce à quoi je serais extrêmement
attentif dans les semaines à venir
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre
[Musique]